thank you
hey everybody what's going on I was over
in the video next door over in the video
next door what video was it that you
were in yeah
I don't know I thought you'd come over
here yeah
I can't come up with anything at a
strange time yeah yeah so we decided to
do a movie review this evening because
we didn't do one on Sunday because we
didn't have time to do a movie and last
night it happened that we did have a
little bit of time to watch a movie but
what ended up happening was that
remember I said that we need to do
um Blackhawk Down because Louie sent us
that and we're still going to do that
we'll probably do that this Sunday like
this coming Sunday but that movie is
like two and a half hours long yeah we
didn't have time and yeah by the time we
finished haunting Mondays last night I
was like we really don't have time and I
was gonna do Megan because somebody told
me oh it's on peacock like it's
streaming for free but it wasn't free
you had to have peacock premium which is
actually only five dollars a month but
we were watching it on our TV and it's
like I have to I'd have to do it through
the phone and like cast and I was like I
don't have time for all that so I just
went to Amazon Prime and I was like oh
look they I have the movie smile from
2022 and I had actually been wanting to
see that because I heard a lot about it
and it was free for us to watch because
we have Amazon Prime and it wasn't
horribly long although it's fairly long
for a horror movie it was almost two
hours but it didn't really seem like it
this was like a pretty solid flick I
thought you know yeah it was shot pretty
well it had uh practical effects and
parts which is nice yeah like there was
some CGI but they really it seemed like
they really tried hard to do mostly
practical and then like with the CGI
just like cleaning it up they were
trying to make it kind of like a classic
horror movie
um but with a new
we're kind of like a you know new
editing you know I mean it felt like a
new movie but I could I could I could
see that they were trying to do
something kind of like you see in the
80s or 90s
just the way I felt about it well the
movie reminds me this was actually the
directorial debut so this is the guy's
first movie uh his name is Parker Finn
and he had made a short film which is
with a similar concept to this and it
was called Laura hasn't slept
and he kind of shopped it around to a
bunch of different film festivals and he
ended up getting a bunch of awards and
it um I think like a an executive at
Paramount like ended up seeing it like
at one of the festivals and really liked
it so said hey why don't you expand that
concept into you know a full-length
movie and what was so this is like a big
budget well it wasn't big budget but it
was released by Paramount although I
think initially it was supposed to just
go straight to streaming it was supposed
to go to Paramount plus uh that's why
they bought it that's why they wanted
him to do it and I think he made it for
17 million
and um when but when they took it around
and they started showing it to like test
audiences like the um the appraisal of
it was like so positive that they said
well [__] maybe we should release it in
theaters and uh it was actually ended up
being a really good idea because as I
said this movie cost 17 million dollars
to make and it made
216 million dollars back like worldwide
so this was actually the weekend it
opened I in at least in the US I think
it was number one and it got like a lot
of really positive now I'm not saying
it's you know it's not fantastic
but it's a solid watch it's the only
criticism it's a little bit and this
isn't even really a criticism because it
doesn't bother me all that much it's a
little bit derivative and I think like a
lot of people are kind of seeing it's
going to remind you of uh Truth or Dare
that's one that a lot of with because
that had that weird like creepy Smiley
thing uh it's gonna remind you of it
follows it has a very similar uh curse
like setup like the the curse the
somebody following you around like and
you don't know who it is uh it's gonna
remind you a little bit of the Ring
there are some actually there are some
scenes in there that are directly
homaging the ring like you can tell that
he did it on purpose
so it's so it's kind of like a
combination of those things but that
said I think it was a really well done I
mean it wasn't just like a knockoff or
it wasn't just like a cash grab or
anything like that it actually had like
a really good story to it it actually
had some really really creepy sequences
in it and I thought it was really well
done there are a lot of jump scares in
it but most of the jump scares I found
were not kind of like cheating jump
scares you know what I mean where it's
just kind of like Boo oh it's like oh it
was just my boyfriend or oh it was just
a cat coming in the window or something
like that like most of the time the jump
scares were actually like the scary
thing you know what I mean so it was so
it wasn't like just a fake out when you
say derivative that's a good way of
putting it because that's what I was it
just reminded me of other stuff yeah it
reminded me really strongly of it
follows
um just in the way it was shot and this
one was like well I don't know like I
guess I was gonna say like I really
liked the way that camera movements were
because it seemed like he did a lot of
stuff with you know the camera being
like upside down or like you know weird
angles like drunk like from drones and
stuff and I really like the way it
wasn't so much that it was overwhelming
or it drew too much attention to itself
but I thought it was well done like a
good way of making it kind of unsettling
also I want to point out this had really
good sound design and that's not usually
something that I would notice unless it
was you know very specifically but I
kind of feel like they put a lot of
effort into the sound design of this one
and I think it was really really
effective and um another thing too is
that
I don't know I just really like the way
that they
the sequences that were like really
really creepy that were like really
really quiet it didn't always have to be
like it had some scenes that were just
like balls to the wall crazy like you
know what I mean but it also had a lot
of sequences where you know it was just
like this real dark room and it's like
is that somebody standing over there by
the wall like you're pretty sure it's
somebody but you can't quite tell or
like somebody's like Whispering from the
closet or something like that and like
the way it was shot and the way the
sound designed it I thought it was like
really effective and like really creepy
the kind of monster it was reminded me
of another movie that I was trying to
put my finger on it
um it's kind of like a demon that jumps
from person to person the only way and
you have a certain amount of time for it
totally takes over
you have to if you kill someone else in
a real violent way it'll jump out of you
and into somebody else if I remember how
it was yeah no how did it go it kind of
reminded me of another movie I think it
might have been dark angel or something
where there's an aliens that we get into
people and then go out and commit a
bunch of crimes
and if you killed that person the alien
would come out of their mouth and you
try to get into another person I think
that might have been Dark Angels a long
time ago for some reason it reminded me
of that it just reminded me of other
stuff what were the rules again
it was basically like a curse it was a
chain that it passed from person to
person like you would people would
commit suicide
and you in front of someone else and if
they committed suicide in front of you
then you would get it and then you would
start seeing the same crazy [__] they
saw like the smile person like it's not
the same you guys said something about
if you could get rid of it by killing
somebody else right but that was like
the one person okay that that was the
one person that had escaped the curse
yeah but they had to kill someone to do
it like everyone else killed themselves
yeah I guess like after a certain that's
why it kind of reminded me of the Ring
because it was like kind of the whole
time clock element because you know the
ring it's like you watch the creepy
video and then like seven days later you
die or whatever this was kind of like
that it didn't have
um I don't think they ever specified
like a very specific but the they did
kind of when they were doing the
investigation they were kind of like oh
well some people did it like in four
days and some people lasted a week or
something like that but nobody lasted
more than a week like seeing the thing
but and it also kind of reminded me of
it follows because if you didn't see it
follows from 2014 which I feel like most
horror fans have probably seen that but
but um that was like a a similar kind of
curse but it was sexually transmitted
and you never knew like when the it was
coming to get you because it could look
like anybody but only you could see the
person you know what I mean so you'd be
like walking on the street and then
suddenly there was like an old lady like
walking towards you like with purpose
and you'd be like oh [__] that's her but
nobody else could see her you know what
I mean but it was you never knew who it
was because it always looked like a
different person and that's kind of the
same thing here except you knew who it
was because they do that creepy [__]
smile thing which is this is like so
funny because
they did I have to say this is like a
pretty genius marketing thing that they
did because the I I actually managed to
avoid seeing the trailers for this I
know that a lot of people complained
they were like oh my God the trailers
for this were just unavoidable and the
shitty thing about that was that the
trailer gave away probably the scariest
and creepiest like jump scare in it like
the woman the sister like walking toward
the car and then the [__] up [__]
happened I don't want to ruin it but um
but they showed that in the trailer and
I was like I'm glad I didn't see the
trailer because that would have ruin it
because I really liked that scene
because I was like [__] you know what I
mean to like [__] it [__] me up so
but um but the marketing for this was
like ubiquitous so a lot of people went
to see it but one of the things that
they did like a viral marketing kind of
thing was that the studio or the
production company or whatever because
it's Paramount so I guess they have a
lot of money so they would go to like
these televised sporting events like
baseball games or whatever and they
would buy out a bunch of seats like
behind the you know the pitcher or the
catcher rather
and then they would hire actors to sit
in the stands and do and just smile
creepily and stare into the camera for
like a really long time so it would be
on TV
um so they did that like a bunch of
times so like a lot of these televised
sporting events had people in the back
just going
like it's like into the [__] thing
and I was like that's pretty funny
actually and then and then they'd have
like the shirts on and everything so
um you know it like I said it took ideas
from a bunch of other things and what I
didn't know I haven't seen the short
film that this was based on which I
mentioned called was called Laura hasn't
slept the interesting thing about it
though is that the short film
if you've seen this movie
the girl who gives the main character
whose name is Rose the psychiatrist or
the therapist or whatever the girl who
gives her the curse like comes into her
office she gets you know Baker acted or
whatever and she gets like brought to
the hospital like the psychiatric
hospital an emergency and she's
complaining she's like I keep seeing
these people with these creepy smiles
and they're telling me I'm gonna die and
all this other stuff and she's like I
know I sound crazy and all this other
stuff and it turns out that that girl
was played by the same actress who
played Laura in the short and it's the
same character so they actually so this
is almost like a continuation of that
shorts and I'm gonna have to kind of go
back and like watch the short again
because I thought that was like a pretty
clever idea of doing it but yeah it's
basically like in another way that it
reminded me of the ring too is that
because remember the ring you know once
Naomi Watts character like finds the
videotape and watches it and then she
gets the phone call that says hey you're
gonna die in seven days and then she's
like a journalist or whatever so she
goes and does like this mystery like
it's an investigation and this one's
kind of like that too like once
once Rose the therapist the main
character once she realizes that she's
that this curse has perhaps passed on to
her or it could just be that she's
completely delusional they do leave that
possibility open
um but she kind of like tries to
help guys tries to get like her
ex-boyfriend who happens to be a cop
um like on board like to help her
investigate and he's the one that finds
out like the chain of all these people
like it passes from person to person so
it's essentially like a demon that feeds
on trauma I guess and that specific
trauma but like I said they leave open
the possibility that she might be
imagining all of it because there are
some scenes toward the end that suggest
that maybe she's
completely like that she's just like
living in a fantasy world or something
you know what I mean so I kind of like
that they left that possibility open
yeah Zach said to him the movie looked
dull and I'm gonna say that I kind of
agree with you but I think that's kind
of universal to me almost all of the
newer horror movies since like 2010 they
all seem dull to me
um I have a hard time paying attention
to him
so but Jenny seems to like him and she
writes Horrors so she's that's more her
genre
uh so I kind of trust if you like these
new horror movies Jenny's can point you
into the into the directions of the good
ones for me most of them are are dull
um they're just not to my taste I liked
mid-summer
um I that other one upon like further
viewing by the same director I thought
it was bad around the second viewing but
I I actually like that stupid [__] like
La Girona I liked that one and I don't
think there was much to that in terms of
writing I just like the experience I saw
in the big on the big screen
there's I don't know maybe if I'm too
old for horror now or I I don't know
what it is you know what I mean it
doesn't quite
have the same impact as it used to if it
has a Sci-Fi element to it I like it a
lot better
um
they're just just not like it was when I
was a kid you know they're all kind of
dull to me
doesn't mean it's bad though just means
it's not my taste
yeah I mean like I said don't go into
this thinking this is like but you know
this wasn't up there with you know some
of the newer movies that I really really
liked like Barbarian which I thought was
[__] awesome because because that
thing was batshit crazy like it but in a
good way too this one goes a little bit
batshit crazy toward the end but it's
interesting because I think from the
trailers people expected it to be one
way just kind of like your regular Blum
House type of thing and some of those
are fun they're usually just not very
substantive you know what I mean and
they're just full of jump scares and
stuff this one has a bunch of jump
scares too but in a lot of ways I think
they're better done most of them are
better done than because they say
they're not fake outs they're not
anything like that and there is like
some actual kind of like depth to the
story like the acting is really good and
it does have some like good ideas behind
it even though a lot of them are kind of
like homaging other films but like I
said a lot of movies do that so I can't
get too mad about it I mean I actually I
didn't get bored I didn't get you know I
was was like really invested in the
story and the way that it was shot I
thought was really creepy and like some
of the shots the one shot like I said I
don't want to spoil too much about it
but the one shot it's I think if you've
seen it if you've seen the trailer but
where the sister walks toward the car
and then like knocks on the car window
and then yeah yeah that was like really
freaky and then there was a scene that
was very clearly homaging one in the
ring where you know that's you know that
very famous scene in the ring that like
almost made me [__] my pants the first
time I watched it in the theater where
the mom and Naomi Watts are like talking
about oh finding her dead daughter or
whatever in the closet and then like
they smash cut to that and it was like
really [__] up looking
so they did something like that here
like they had the main character Rose
she goes to the you know surviving Widow
of like one of the last dude in the
chain you know what I mean like the
demon smile suicide chain
and uh she goes there and the woman is
describing like finding him dead and
then they smash cut to like him in the
morgue and his face is all [__] up and
it was like it looked like it was like
practically done too and I was like oh
nicely done one thing I am gonna and if
you've seen the movie you probably know
what I'm gonna say
foreign
there is an adorable cat in this movie
named mustache
and
the cat doesn't make it and honestly
like well you know
because right near the beginning of the
movie they make a big deal of her like
putting food in a bowl and like putting
it down and calling him by his name and
I was like oh yeah some sick and it
[__] up is gonna happen to that cat
and something real [__] up happens to
that cat
um I kind of saw it coming like as soon
as that was another really good scene
even though I was like no because
because it was like you know a kitty and
it's I can't really [__] I I can't
like watch that kind of [__] anymore
like you know killed people kill
children kid whatever just leave the
[__] animals alone you know what I
mean they didn't show the cat getting
killed but there was like a dead cat
kind of thing but I did kind of see
where that was going because they made a
big deal about hey have you seen the cat
and blah blah blah and then there's a
scene where she goes to this birthday
party and I'm just like uh oh I'm like
that's gonna pay off and I don't know if
I want to like be here for it but yeah
so that really did upset me but other
than that like I said it's not I don't
want to oversell it I'm just saying that
I think if you kind of like I don't know
I think it's like two it's it's kind of
mean to say it's just like oh middle of
the road or whatever because I think
that it's kind of like those sort of
blumhousie kind of movies but like a
notch or two above that you know what I
mean I feel like the acting is better
um it's scarier it's creepier like some
of the stuff like looked like it was
better done it was better made Zach said
something I agree with right there that
he he's getting close to it why don't
you read it where
for me a lot of modern horror movies
just kind of lack a certain Humanity to
them yeah that gets me to really care
about the characters and [__] it's hard
to explain well I mean like the
characters are kind of thin or they're
the tone of the characters is very
uniform so there's no real differences
between the characters I think earlier
horror movies you had like silly
character you had like a hot girl
character you had another dude who's
like a Chad character and it was a it
was a variety of characters and they're
kind of like archetypes it was something
that kind of added a certain texture to
it some of the people you could relate
to them because they weren't realistic
and which that's crazy to Santa but it's
kind of like something out of
Shakespearean type you know how you know
how the all the bit Parts in
Shakespearean plays were kind of like
caricatures you know they're like yeah
there was something about it they gave a
horror movie a certain kind of fantasy
tone which if the if the story was good
it kind of pulled you into it it felt
colorful and I think that's what it is
I think Zach is right or he's on to
something it's at least partly right
decana a lot of the modern
horror kind of lacks texture when it
comes to
the characters they're all too realistic
or too dry something like that I I I'm
he's right it's hard to explain there's
something missing I don't know what
they're doing wrong well I mean I've you
know our I've seen a lot more modern
horror movies than you have yeah and I
don't generally have that problem
um and I had that problem with like
older movies too I guess yeah it just it
depends it depends on like the story it
depends on the characters I think the
characters are really important
um now that speaking of that I think the
only issue I had with that in this movie
was I thought that her fiance character
um he wasn't in it enough and I heard
later like I was watching another review
and they said well most of his scenes
and he was played by um the guy from uh
the boys I think like his name his
character name is a train or something
but um but he was in this and he played
her fiance and he was kind of in it
quite a bit at the beginning but then
like he almost kind of like well they
sort of kind of broke up or whatever but
then like you didn't really see him
again and I thought he was a little
underdeveloped but when I went and
watched some other reviews they said
well they did a bunch more scenes with
him and like with the two of them like
interacting like establishing their
relationship and stuff but they cut most
of that out so
um you know so so I guess that's maybe
why because I think that her
ex-boyfriend the cop who was helping her
with the investigation was a much more
rounded character I mean this is to be
honest this is mostly I mean the main
character
um what is her name she's she's Kevin
Bacon's daughter like the the woman that
is the main you know Kevin Bacon and
Kyra Sedgwick who've been married for
[__] ever this uh it's their daughter
so see bacon that's her name
it's weird because we were watching it
at Tom's like that looks like Ali Sheedy
and like it does a bit but it's yeah
it's Kevin Bacon's daughter isn't that
funny I didn't even realize that but uh
yeah so she's the main character and I
mean her she's great I think she's she's
been in some other stuff too but I think
she was like really really good in this
like she brought a really because
the thing about it is that I I'm always
really freaked out in movies by the
whole like gaslighting thing because
like if if you legit
if if this was real if there was like a
demon that's like you know that passed
on to trauma and you know uh would cause
you to kill yourself and stuff like no
one would believe you and it's so it's
like super frustrating like watching her
just losing her [__] Marbles and like
everybody just thinks she's a complete
nut case even though it's clearly really
happening maybe but the thing about it
is that they kind of leave it ambiguous
and I think that was probably the right
decision because you don't know like you
know maybe she was just imagining all of
it I don't know
Hugo said hi everybody this flick was
fun yeah I actually quite enjoyed it uh
Vandal cabbage says have y'all seen that
skinamarink movie I've seen it I did a
review of it a little while back I
actually really liked it but
if you haven't seen it it's going to be
one of those movies that's like super
super divisive you're either really
really really gonna Vibe with it or
you're really really really not you know
you're just really gonna think it's
boring because it's more
it's not a narrative movie in the purest
sense it's kind of like it's a it's a
mood piece more than a movie but if you
are in that Vibe and if you kind of get
into that Vibe then it's super creepy
but you really have to kind of be in the
mood for it you know what I mean
uh Juggernaut the film surprised me it
was way better than it should have been
I kind of feel like a lot of reviewers
that I watched said that like um because
I saw kind of your kind of your big
bigger guys like Cody Leach and uh Chris
stuckman and stuff they actually saw the
premiere of this at Fantastic Fest like
last year and then they did a review of
it like on their channel so I watched
them earlier today and all of them said
pretty much the same thing they're like
well from the trailer we were expecting
it to be kind of like a blumhousey like
just a kind of
lame jump scary kind of movie but they
were like actually it was way better
than we were expecting like there was a
lot more to it than the trailers made it
seem I think the trailer kind of most of
that stuff happens like in the First Act
of the movie and then like it kind of
goes in a different direction
but I don't know I think it was like I
said I don't want to oversell it too
much but
if you like that kind of movie like a
sort of Blum Housey kind of movie but
like a couple notches above that like a
bit better like with better shot
composition like creepier better acting
then this would probably be like I said
it's not the plot of it is kind of like
takes pieces from it's like a bit of a
magpie conglomeration of like some other
like it follows in the ring and Truth or
Dare and stuff like that but that's okay
though I mean you know that's how many
movies do we have about demon possession
how many movies how many Haunted House
movies do we have it's like you can't
there's only so many things you can make
movies or write stories about
um but if you're gonna make something
like that like just make it good like
make it enjoyable and I actually quite
enjoyed this like I said I wasn't bored
I wasn't I thought it was like really
creepy some of the scenes were like
really good
um a couple of the scenes like really
got me like that were like really freaky
and [__] like that but yeah I thought it
was like pretty decent so you know and
we're gonna do Megan too but um because
I've really heard a lot of good stuff
about that but that's kind of that might
be more your bad because I kind of feel
like that's probably like more sci-fi
based I'm looking at the trailer and I'm
going that's probably good yeah I've
heard that it's really good but like I
said I try to avoid trailers I'm really
glad that I didn't see the trailer for
this one because a lot of reviewers
complained it's like oh my God the
trailer was everywhere and it ruined a
bunch of the best scenes
um but I managed to not see the trailer
before I saw this so all the scenes like
got me you know what I mean because I
really do try to like not I don't read
this this summary I don't watch the
trailers I don't do anything like that I
don't seek them out because I like to
just
see the movie like and it's whatever
all right so um I know this has been a
little bit short but I have a whole
bunch of other stuff that I have to do
before we go to bed so uh I guess we'll
cut it short if you have Amazon Prime
um this is on there it's streaming on
there for free at the moment and you
know I would recommend it it's not the
best movie ever but it's pretty good I
mean I thought it was pretty solid
so tomorrow is Wednesday and that's our
main show and tomorrow night I said this
last night but we're finally gonna do a
topic that I've been wanting to do for a
really long time which is The
Disappearance of Louis laprince who is
ostensibly the true father of
cinematography the true inventor of the
ocean picture camera who disappeared
very mysteriously back in the late 19th
century so uh it's actually a really
fascinating story and that's what we're
going to be doing the show about
tomorrow night at 7 30 p.m Eastern
Standard Time so hopefully you guys can
be here for that so remember to like and
comment and all that other kind of stuff
for algorithm purposes and we will see
you guys again tomorrow night
good night